hello hello testing testing one two one
two test test thick nasty rhythms
special delivery one fat [ __ ] coming up
oh and welcome to another episode of
trash days probably should have start
with that uh I'm your host for today
gaunts and with me again are the boys
Joey really wants me to say the [ __ ]
but uh I uh can we actually not because
we're gonna get demonetized then we're
gonna be like why do we get demonetized
again some [ __ ] stupid name yeah if
we get demonetized by saying that word I
don't want to be on this platform
Debussy
let's go I heard blips doing really
really well I don't remember blip
remember I want to be a blipper
that just sounds inappropriate
anyway do you know what uh do you know
what I found myself missing recently
that I never thought I'd miss what
American portion sizes so okay I want to
hear this story yes so I went to I went
to eat at an Italian restaurant
yesterday and here's the thing about
Japanese portion sizes right obviously
they're smaller than the rest of the
world this feels like an AI generated
conversation is it from trash taste
conversations yes okay it is it is
let me talk let me just start with the
most AI generated trash taste topic I
could think of it just um so food yeah
just food just food so we've complained
the portrait sizes are too big in
America yeah now we're complaining
they're too small here yes okay yes guys
it's not it's not it's not that it's not
that they're too small so you know you
know how it is when you go to a Japanese
restaurant some Japanese restaurants
give you like good portion slices right
but if it's not Japanese food then they
are way way smaller than what you can
expect in you know others especially
especially Italian food and especially
especially especially Pizza like I don't
know what it is about Japanese pizzas
but like large size in Japan is like
medium to small size anywhere else in
the world yeah right yeah so me and
Cindy go to this Japanese restaurant uh
and we wanted some pasta or pizza well I
I was a fat ass so I like I wanted both
you know you know you know that you know
that you know that feeling where you
kind of like you kind of want two dishes
at once but they're like two Mains and
I'm like yo Sydney a set of like
ordering starters do you wanna do you
wanna share a pizza with me as a starter
or just have that as a starter yeah and
then we'll have passer afterwards Yeah
Yeah so basically
in any other country you could I don't
think I can get away with this because
the pizza would be too big but in Japan
I was like this is a country I can get
away with ordering a pizza as a starter
yeah
um and so the waitress comes over
and uh we order the pizza and she's like
okay waiting for us to get to the other
Mains and then I was and then we go uh
yeah can we order two dishes of the
large size of the pasta because even the
medium size of the pasta is small as
[ __ ] yeah we need to order compared to
America yeah compared to America and
she's like excuse me where where who's
who's the two pastors for and it's like
oh no can we have the pizza as a starter
so you can bring out the pizza before
the mains and there was like
but she was like and she looked at the
piece and she's like but that's not a
starter are you sure you want this and
then we go yeah yeah yeah we're sure
we're sure and then she goes off looking
confused and we see her talking to the
manager she literally talks to her she
talks to her manager and then she like
she has this Panic look on her face
because obviously we're two we're two
foreigners in a in a restaurant that's
full of attack sorry full of Japanese
people she comes back over and she goes
uh uh I know it's mimason and she's like
can I just confirm with you the order
just just so you understand the pastor
by itself the large size is normally
shared between two people and you order
two of them so the the portion sizes
that you ordered would be normally for
around three to four people
we just went yes it is uh we are sure we
understand what we have just ordered
thanks for confirming that we're a bunch
of fat-offs you've got the real match
Stoney ordering experience yeah yeah
yeah so she brings all the pizza and
then she brings over the pasta and me
and Sydney both [ __ ] destroy this
pasta even like even though this is the
large size I'll be honest it didn't
actually fill me up
here's my like in Japan right yeah this
is how you visualize it I feel like when
I order a large pasta I can always pick
up all of the pasta in one hand yeah
it is like a perfect if I can pick it
all up with one hand you have not given
me enough pasture and I'm always tempted
I'm like I just wanna yeah this is what
you think is enough to feed me okay yeah
and and so like we finish it there's not
even like a drop of sauce left on this
bottle right and she comes back over and
she looks at me she looks at her empty
balls and she's she's just like I see
you enjoyed the pasta and I was just
like oh God I feel you're judging eyes
okay I feel them I feel them okay don't
judge me anymore all right she wasn't
even like subtle about it she might as
well have just been like so how many
days has it been since you haven't eaten
yeah and then she takes them away and
then she comes back over and she's like
would you like any dessert on top of
that I'm like no okay I'm a fat ass okay
you can say it you can say it okay I get
it okay well fat asses okay okay don't
you don't need to say anymore I don't
want dessert okay [ __ ] son you want some
[ __ ] Desire with that just give me
the bill okay just give me the bill I
get it okay I get it I'll just cry I'll
just go home and cry
no no I was about to say like I feel my
personal experience with eating like
Italian food like pizza or pasta in
Japan is that it's either way too little
or way too much yeah there's no too much
of [ __ ] yeah it's like yeah the too much
is always [ __ ] yeah
well if it's the too much they give you
like 90 pastor and 10 sauce so it's like
mostly just raw pasta and there's just
like 0.1 coating on each piece it's like
essence of sauce
personally I think the going back to
what you're saying earlier that when you
when you say something in Japan that
isn't the normal system that they have
of like say dining or whatever it's it's
so frustrating in Japan yeah it's like
you can see the error codes in a
debugging menu when you when you say
something where you're like what you
want a main to come out before another
main are you yeah what is on top of
ordering two extra large it's like if
you explain this in any European country
maybe they'd be like are you sure like
whatever but like it would get done
right yeah in America okay we get it
sure okay we'll bring it up first but
like in Japan it's like it's like you've
asked if you could like wed their
daughter
the reaction they give you is so so
weird they need time to think about it
and again it's that whole thing of like
it's the Panic it's like why are you
panicking
because because in Japan when they train
employees like that it's just like buy
the book yeah and if there's anything
that's an exception into that book then
it's just first reaction immediately
Panic ask the manager it's like bro it's
not that it's not that deep I'm like in
my head I'm just I'm just confused at
what what are they what thoughts are
going through the head that their first
response is oh what the [ __ ] they're
freaking out yeah I don't know why they
think like oh is this allowed in this
establishment like yes this is allowed
oh they think at some point that we're
going to be frustrated or annoyed at
them and it's like no no I if you can't
do it yeah you can't do it yeah I I I'm
not gonna throw a fit but like I feel
like I violated some law or I've done
something wrong I think what it is I'm
sorry I didn't I didn't want to cause
trouble I just wanted my pastor before
my pizza I'm so sorry I I'm trying I'm
trying to muster up all of my like
Japanese side to like try and figure out
what the thought process of it is and I
think
big quotations I think what it is is
that they don't want the this idea of
like miscommunication yeah I understand
I understand they're like are you sure
this is what you want because we don't
want you we don't want to you know make
all this [ __ ] we don't want the chef to
go all this through this hardship yeah
bring it out and then you go that's not
what I wanted yeah I understand I can
understand that yeah to the point where
it would
drive you to have a little bit of a
momentary Panic about it I feel like
come on well because I think the blame
is going to be pushed on the waiter
right
I mean maybe they've had some bad
experiences that way too yeah sure I
can't I can't I don't know what they've
lived through right no I don't know
where they've waited yeah did they serve
Papa John or something yeah I don't I
want 30 pizzas it's like
are you sure about that
and you'll get the slot in Japan right
and this is a question that will happen
if you're eating lunch only lunch
you go to lunch right right you order
again let's just say a pasta you order a
pastor it's always a pasta yeah let's
say uh let's say you order the pasta and
you're you're you know you want to drink
with it you wanna uh berry smoothie or a
coffee whatever you want to know why I
said berries
every single timer and this will happen
in Japan right so if you're coming here
and you don't know they'll ask you yeah
and they'll say it in Japanese obviously
they're like do you want the drink
before or after your meal yeah and I've
always found this really odd because in
any other country you don't get it after
the meal that doesn't happen so I've
always done this I've always been
confused by this concept and the default
is after so yeah you don't I think
though it depends on the drink
right if it's a coffee I would
understand why they would ask it right
because it's to a Japanese person
drinking a coffee with a full-on meal is
a bit weird why is that weird yeah in
Japan it is I don't understand this
concept of why I would if I'm ordering a
coffee now and I'm ordering my food now
yeah that should tell you that drinks
always come first right actually I
didn't notice that because I'm like
every time I ordered a coffee I'm like
always I want the coffee first yeah yeah
right every single time you order a
drink anywhere anywhere in the world the
drink always comes first yeah because I
think in Japan the the idea of coffee is
that it's like an after meal drink yeah
kind of like you know like tea or you
know some other you know like uh not not
exactly like refreshing beverages that
go with the meal yeah so I think they
kind of treat it like that and so when
you say I want the coffee before the
meal or during the meal that's kind of
out of the book I I would understand
that for dinner yeah because dinner you
typically but then afterwards they come
after the meal they're like do you want
to teal no no no in Japan it's only in
Japan if you order a coffee during
dinner time they just like stop
panicking
they're like 6PM but like this is n't on
this is even on the menu
I've been to they always at the end of
the meal you've had your dessert yeah or
with the dessert order do you want to
see your coffee yeah normal no other
time to ever have a coffee with my yes
so it's only with lunch and then for
some yeah I get it only it only happens
with tea and coffee and I'm like just
just give me it I've ordered it now give
me it now if I want another coffee after
I drink my coffee I'll have that but
yeah but that's only yeah because you go
through coffee like it's nothing I just
but I always tell them as well like I
always say before but then sometimes
there's like this weird confusion where
they're like oh oh okay see because it
makes sense in a cafe setting in Japan
like if you just go to like a regular
Cafe in the morning or at lunch time and
you have a coffee with say you know like
a [ __ ] Panini or something or like a
small sandwich right yeah I always want
the coffee then then they'll then they
won't bow tonight they'll be like oh yes
of course you want a coffee with that
exactly but I think it's this idea of
having a full-on sit-down meal and
having a coffee with it that's weird for
some reason I drink hot green tea here
with our meals right yeah yeah like
there's another attack Society Society
Japanese Society there's another place
that was an Italian place that did lunch
things and did the tea and the coffee
yeah they always asked they always asked
me do I want it before or after or they
would just bring it out by after default
yeah and I always just thought well
we're eating pasta here give me the
[ __ ] coffee yeah yeah Italians are
crying right now yeah yeah I noticed
there's no way as a as a foreigner to
order pizza not feel like a [ __ ] fat
ass I mean ordering pizza already you
feel like a [ __ ] fat ass but like in
Japan it's the norm to order pizza to
share with everyone yeah but me I'm like
the norm for me is ordering at least one
pizza in Japan just for me and if I'm
feeling spicy I'll order one and share
another one with a mate you know yeah
because like the the pizza for one
person in Japan is like the size of a
large floppy disk like it's it's barely
a meal yeah the large size that they
recommend for three or four people
that's a medium size I can destroy that
easily easily if you know if I'm feeling
hungry that's I need a [ __ ] large
size pizza all right yeah yeah did you
see that uh Domino's Pizza went out of
business in Italy did I actually well
they left they left sorry I presume I
mean well I mean they got chased out
they got chased down they're like you're
not a real Pizza they opened 2015 I
think and then yeah they left damn so uh
yeah
apparently you know didn't want uh
Domino's Pizza wow it sucks to have the
option gone right right it sucks is
Olive Garden still around there I don't
have Olive Garden are you kidding me I
think Domino's Pizza was pushing their
luck yeah did I have Pizza Hut there
that's us that's a legit question yeah
yeah I would assume not all right maybe
Kai can jack first yeah Kai is there any
American pizza joints in Italy I would
assume if they do it'd be like one or
two in the city you know yeah like that
kind of yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
probably be like finding a Panda Express
in China or something like that right I
don't what would be what would the
equivalent be yeah I mean but when you
think about it it's like such a [ __ ]
backhanded thing to do to go all the way
to like say Rome right right and then
being like [ __ ] man
really want a dominoes right now it's
like I I think I prefer a lot of
countries it's it's kind of banking on
the uh a lot of foreign people and also
the ease of it yeah the familiarity of
it yeah and you know if you order a
Domino's Pizza you know that's just
gonna be delivered you know what I mean
yeah you don't have to call up you can
do it online so like I think they Bank a
lot of the time on convenience and ease
yeah I mean like part of the especially
traveling around I've valued way more
now just having big name brands that I
recognize because of course yeah you
know you want to go out your comfort
zone you want to try to local Cuisine
but sometimes you just want something
where you know what to expect I love
that there's a McDonald's everywhere
exactly exactly when the countries are
like yeah we didn't [ __ ] let
McDonald's in I'm like all right well I
mean I would have liked it but I guess
I'm like that's my capitalist brain that
has been trained to be a slave to Ronald
I actually like going to McDonald's in
every country just to it's cool it's one
it's one thing that you go to everywhere
you go we've been brainwashed so well
well no because to me it's like because
it's like I know I've been to enough
McDonald's in different countries now
where I know every McDonald's in every
country tastes different yeah in some
regards but it's still and like I could
put like a tier list of like McDonald's
of different colors it still tastes
familiar enough that you can point to
something and you're like okay I kind of
know what this is of course like it's
not like going to you know it's not like
going to a restaurant and ordering
something and you're gonna get like
[ __ ] uh chicken heart or some stuff
you know which is a thing that can
happen if you're a tourist here in Japan
you just order something you don't know
what you're gonna get sometimes I mean I
I remember you know when I went to a
McDonald's in France one time just
because I kind of felt like it and I I
felt so invigorating when I finally
ordered
yeah I was like absolutely
dude I've got mayonnaise on everything
Joey okay they do they put mayonnaise on
everything dude it's a good it's a good
moment when you go to McDonald's in
America and you realize wow this is the
worst one oh it absolutely absolutely
I know I know this is why you can never
Bank on the home of something being the
best version of it I mean look at
football right just just you know the
British the British invented it and
everyone did it yeah are you sure about
that yes and Cricket as well I'm pretty
sure about that I'm pretty sure let's
get a fact check on it I'm I'm almost
100 sure which country invented football
or soccer
we've got an international audience we
have to say soccer
even though it pains me
I feel like we didn't why I feel like
every country made football what
every [ __ ] country figured out that
you kick a [ __ ] thing around into a
goal like no you know what I mean like
you can say that oh the UK made it but I
bet they're like Babylonians were
kicking heads into something I'm so glad
we have a fact Checker
okay I refuse to believe right that
England made England England is the
country that saw a spherical shapes
thing and was like we should start
kicking this around and turn it into a
sport they probably like legitimized it
and made it into like a yeah did they
invent the sport yes did they invent the
concept of kicking around objects
probably not you know probably like the
[ __ ] cavemen
okay cavemen were kicking beheaded heads
around probably at one point they have
multiple sources some say China
something Italian Italy some say Greece
I feel like every country could have a
claim team like we're the first guys who
invented kicking around things you know
well that's like saying like who
invented baseball and who was the first
human to ever get a long object and hit
a [ __ ] spherical thing with it but
there's like there's like there's um uh
what's the word there's a very uh like
Primal not Primal uh primitive versions
of sports where maybe uh a place with a
group of people played this game and it
was a tradition where they played it but
it was never officially like a sport or
anything but now the real question is
what's the oldest sport
what was the first sport who invented
sport I'm gonna be honest fighting to
the death yeah probably UFC that's
probably the oldest sport fighting to
them
I mean come on let's just be straight
away yeah yeah that's true I mean I mean
was it a sport or was it just an
activity it was just some bands
I mean killing your homies yeah sport
goes really far back I mean you have the
whole uh Greeks right
and then you have like they would have
the olympiads yeah yeah trained and then
they they were I mean I think that was
the first ever documented people who
just trained for sport not for like War
yeah as far as I remember yeah that's
right I mean I feel like yeah I mean I
feel like a lot of sport was born out of
activities that were probably life or
death activities back in the day yeah
and then when Society evolved to a point
where they don't need to [ __ ] kill
each other they're like but we kind of
still want to like hit each other and
you know and do all this information
yeah builders stuff you know I think we
have some facts yes yeah I mean that's
pretty correct the first ball was
wrestling wrestling that makes sense I
mean are you telling me that like the
like it just seems so right for the
Primal brain yeah from from Monkey
Brains like the first thing we want to
do is just start seeing it's like I
don't want to fight but I want to watch
the big two guys I want to watch the two
big guys like that's that sounds good I
mean that's the whole fun like are you
new to this day
yeah it's still really popular I mean
it's it's you see a fight and there's
just something Primal about it you know
I've made someone go yeah yeah yeah kind
I mean they're kind of right like the
subreddits of like [ __ ] people
fighting on the street is like super
popular world star apparently people
love their [ __ ] I mean love it I mean I
don't I don't think it's a coincidence
that you know back I'm back when I go
out clubbing or whatever back when you
know Lads coach was a massive thing it's
you'd see so many guys as in Dancing
with like clubbing club dancing is one
drink away from Fighters like look
basically you see a load of lads out you
know and either they'd try to get with
girls and if they didn't succeed then
add alcohol in that and you'd like most
of the time you'd see a fight somewhere
in a club you know and I think that just
goes back to what's that just there's
just something Primal about that right
yeah that's that's what like the case is
either sex or violence that's you know
well now we have the beta male
generation where nobody wants to fight
each other and we have these docile
brains and we we've been brainwashed by
five these herbivore men
well you're emitting some herbivore
energy around the carnival right now
baby I want that meat
oh my God that's such a better word than
beta I just want to call people we are
we are probably the most of all the
popular podcasts we're probably the most
beta podcast I think we are we never
like Relish in fights or enjoy the
masculinity of men we just kind of just
mean like I've been eating salads every
day I'm definitely this close to being a
[ __ ] herbivore man we've ever had
like an alpha conversation yeah like any
any
what what constitutes us an alpha
conversation Connor in your mind I mean
okay when you play clips of our podcast
aside Joe Rogan jokes like there's a man
who can crack a skull open up in
Ethiopia and he drinks the Flesh of the
the brain stem to claim that he's the
chief of the tribe you know that's like
the conversations they have and I watch
ours and I'm like who why is everyone
watching our podcast I don't like orange
juice
high chair talking about boneless
like I I watched that and I'm like why
is anyone watching a podcast we that's
what the real estate
maybe it's because it's like our podcast
isn't trying to be fake yeah I'll try to
be this kind of manly ass it's like wait
listen we're all we're all babies I have
a wife I don't need to attract uh
anymore he's about ensuring that even
when you're an alpha that you're still
an alpha you're not a you're not like
tied down to one beta woman well also
we don't have a course that we're trying
to sell
the alpha course actually uh now we
would like to announce the herbivore
course
before it's about eating well yeah you
know
you won't be needing those uh it's about
uh you know just getting a really good
score on Scrabble and making sure that
like you're you know your brain age is
making sure that your 401k today yeah
honestly make sure you keeping up with
your daily word
[Music]
when's the last time you talked to your
mum
the sigma body appeal in a world with
these Alpha wannabe podcasts it's nice
to have a beta boy podcast you know
being a boy
podcasts
maybe it's Sigma that we don't care
about being Alphas so we're the sigma
beta I mean I feel like I feel like you
could turn any mindset into being a
supervisor because all you need to do is
uh make a meme and just put like the
Giga Chad chin next to next to an image
of whatever like mindset I want an edit
of the Giga chat guy eating a salad
that's our podcast this episode is
sponsored by GameStops attention Gamers
the Council of Gamers has arrived guys
did you know sugar isn't good for you
what's great
but we're in America right now I know I
know if you need a clean energy drink
with no crashes no sugar and tastes
amazing drink gamer Subs did you know
guys that game of Subs is a zero calorie
Energy Formula that is keto friendly
diabetic friendly and is a guilt-free
healthy energy drink that you can drink
throughout the day that keeps you calm
and alert well let me give a taste do
you feel gamer this is the most
healthiest I've been in all of America
so far if you don't need
to replace all the sugar crap you're
drinking we have a caffeine free version
they have a bunch of weird flavors like
of course emotional damage what flavors
would you like to see viewers and what
names would you like to see for them and
did you know a guy's good friend of the
show shibuyakaho had the lead animator
for Bleach draw the front and back of
her brand new waifu cup it goes for sale
from the 7th of October and will
continue until the 17th of October so
get in quick guys so guys become a true
gamer today and get some new awesome
Cups by clicking the link in the
description and using Code trash taste
at the checkouts taking the game subs
for the sponsor back to the episode did
you listen to other podcasts or any of
those I don't have time anymore yeah
time for trash days and I realized uh
I'm on one I I listen to you guys enough
I don't need to listen to more guys talk
to Sam do you have anything for his car
you look you want to say something oh
okay okay he's just he's just intently
listening I used to try and listen to
other podcasts I used to try and listen
to The Joe Rogan one of them a really
exciting guest and some of them were fun
he does sometimes have a good way of
getting conversation to flow in a
certain way I mean there's you know I
agree with his opinions [ __ ] no no no no
uh but does he sometimes a good host I
mean there's a reason why he's so I was
gonna say there's a reason why he's as
successful as he is it sucks sometimes
that we have to practice like I don't
like his views and it's like I can't
just be like that man's a good host
there's a reason why he's doing well
yeah but doesn't automatically mean that
I I agree with everything he says which
I agree with barely anything no yes no
well I don't think there's anything
wrong with listening to you know another
Viewpoint that you might not necessarily
agree with I agree I agree like I think
in fact that helps you keep a more open
mind and have a healthier mindset
because I do it all the time even like
it's weird because there's been times in
like my let's say internet history where
I've got like the odd comment of just
like oh why is gigock surprise subscribe
to this person I'm following this person
he must follow their views or something
and I'm like no like I think sometimes I
just want to see what that guy's saying
just to see how the other side thinks
sometimes or how that view of uh how
that view of that person is like uh like
put out there yeah because I think it's
important to at least know what
everyone's saying otherwise you're just
gonna be stuck in your own little bubble
if anything like a lot of the YouTubers
I like watching like podcasts or not are
the ones where I barely ever agree with
what they're actually saying but yeah
the way that they frame that opposite
opinion that they might have to me is so
interestingly presented that it just
makes me listen and like at the end of
the video you know I might not agree
with it necessarily but I'm like well
you know it was still a good video
because now I got a better more you know
I guess nuanced opinion yeah of the
other side yes you know yeah as you said
like it opens up like I love watching
needle drop for that reason because like
I barely ever agree with the opinions he
has on music right but it's still
interesting to hear his opinion yeah
it's like oh okay you know I might not
agree with that opinion necessarily but
the way that he phrased that particular
opinion makes me think about all of my
other opinions on other [ __ ] that I
might have because it just opens me up
to a new idea if that makes sense yeah I
guess so yeah yeah speaking of Alphas
though I I don't this is this is a
complete [ __ ] tangent right because
like one of the coolest pieces of
culture I I just I think about and I
just talk about Alphas for some reason
remind me of this yeah
um just like the New Zealand what's
what's the New Zealand dance called Haka
Haka bro that's like that is Alpha like
I'm thinking about okay what piece of
culture from your home country are you
proud of because I think out of
everything that I can think of in terms
of like every country Haka is by far one
of the coolest pieces of culture I just
I have just seen I agree just like being
being broadcasted in the world right my
favorite is like when the the New
Zealand rugby team yeah they do a Haka
before every single match right because
it's tradition yeah but at the same time
it's also [ __ ] hilarious seeing the
opposite team just watching that and
[ __ ] themselves yeah because like
you try to like keep your cool but how
do you even react to that it is one of
the most intimidating things it is it's
a witness especially when it's like 250
kilo I built brick [ __ ] house rugby
players and they're just like I am going
to destroy you yeah they could get
[ __ ] destroyed in that match and I I
don't care because all I'm gonna
remember is that first like they went
into it with an album with the real
Alphas they came out the alphas man they
don't need to win today really cool
video as well like and and because I
remember there was a moment where I was
just like obsessed with the Haka because
I thought it was just such a [ __ ]
cool thing right
um but like there's this really cool
video that I saw and like I I looked
into like you know what the hacker is
and like what the significance of it is
and stuff like that and it's it's it's
this traditional dance that's done by
the maoris which are the indigenous new
zealanders
um but there's this really cool one
where they do it at weddings as well and
there's this really cool video of this
like uh Maori woman marrying uh a white
guy like from New Zealand and the and
the Maori woman her family does a hawker
for her to be initiated into this
marriage yeah and it's really bizarre
but also really [ __ ] cool I've seen
that video because out of context you're
like because they're doing this Haka
dance right which is in these like suits
it's like isn't the hawk and it didn't
come from like a war dance that they
would do before going to [ __ ] War to
intimidate the other side yeah so like
you imagine this kind of War dance at a
wedding right and this this girl because
this uh the dance has so much meaning
she's like she's like crying because it
means a lot but if you don't know the
contacts
it's just a bunch of buff dudes two two
like dancing to this bride go ah I'm
just like shouting and you're just like
what the hell is going on right now but
it's so cool because like that
particular video I wish I could remember
the name of it it's on YouTube but like
it's like it wouldn't be hard it
wouldn't be hard to find but like it's
it also shows like the translations of
what they're saying in the Maori
language yeah and it's really [ __ ]
poetic and beautiful yeah because it's
literally just like the the family being
like you are grown up now we are ready
to let you go but we are also ready to
invite you back in yeah kind of thing
yeah and it's really cool because like
the white guy as well he's intimidated
at first but then he joins in yeah and
it's like it's such a cool fight like it
is such a cool [ __ ] bonding
experience that I don't think many other
cultures have I'm jealous because I wish
like I wish we had a caught like a
culture that was like that cool instead
of just like getting [ __ ] piss head
drunk and just passing out
you can do both yeah
if you do a hacker beforehand that just
makes it ten times more cool boys night
happens before everyone starts like
have you have we spoke about uh the
culturist I just like Thailand
everything cool culture-wise that you do
it guys dude
um I'm trying to think I mean I feel
like I've spoken it doesn't have to be
as intense as the Hawker but no not as
not as intense as the Harker but I'm not
I'm trying I'm trying to think off the
top I know we have like a lot of
cultural stuff I'm trying to think of
like cultural activities that as just
like really that is cool I guess does
what would you say is like the British
thing which I don't know of any British
I know there's like the I think I can't
remember if I spoke about on the focus
for the Welsh one with the Maris Lloyd
someone with the horse head oh yes yes I
think so yeah remember that one someone
where like uh there's a horse skeleton
uh head so this is a skull yeah skeleton
just the Hat the skull and I'm like a
stick and then a white robe uh and
someone underneath it and you like knock
on someone's door they don't do any more
on the doors at least not where I grew
up we do it like all self-contained but
typically the whole tradition I can't
remember why we do it you would go
around knock on doors and then you'd
have like a poetry battle and if you won
the Poetry bag poetry battle Yeah if you
did like bro that's badass
Eight Mile
well because like poetry singing is all
like a very easy spin that [ __ ] it's
like a really big part of the culture so
if you want to won the Poetry battle
yeah as the person uh knocking on the
door you get to take all of their all
like a good chunk of alcohol I think
from them
it's like damn dude
I think it was and I when I did it it
was never like that it was it was it was
different to that but there was poetry
involved it's like herbivore yeah
so poetry is like a really really
important big part of uh Welsh called
poetry and Welsh must sound so [ __ ]
bad that's what it looks like I think
you've seen this before right put it up
on screen Moodle yeah you've seen this
oh yeah yeah yeah weird
um yeah I think you would I don't know
if we have anything like that in
Australia because I don't think well I
think the problem is is that our culture
just isn't really old enough yeah so
I've established tradition so I think a
lot of our Traditions are just British
ones that have lasted all kind of maybe
changed a little bit yeah yeah or just
Traditions we've borrowed from other
countries okay yeah because I I'd say
like the one one thing like the
Americans have definitely done like very
successfully is we we talk about what
you know we we wonder what America's
biggest export is but I think America's
most successful successful export has
been their culture yeah because everyone
in the world knows about American
culture whether it's be like through TV
shows the soft power of uh Hollywood yes
is I mean it's insane yeah you know and
it's it's like you go you go here to
Japan you go to China you hear songs in
the Billboard 100 you know even even if
you know no one here understands what
they're saying you still hear it here
see that's interesting you say that
though because I've heard from a lot of
Americans that claim that America has no
culture oh America does definitely have
like yeah I think I think I think
they're just kind of like blind to it
but I think yeah as you were saying like
you know the fact that you can hear
[ __ ] Billy eilish and Justin Bieber
well anywhere in the world yeah when
your culture is the well one of the most
dominant cultures in the world it's easy
to think that you have no culture
because the the best yeah the normal is
yours yeah yeah that's you know it's not
it's not the case uh also yeah it's not
poetry I forgot it's um the householders
would be expected so you go in someone's
house you ask to enter uh to drink yeah
and they they can you sing to each other
person has to sing back and just keep
denying you and if you just keep asking
to go in and they eventually just fold
you go in and you drink that
so wait so what if it just goes on
forever I assume you can just keep going
or they'll move on to another house it's
like 12 hours later they're just like no
it's just a no you I know like nearly
all the traditions in Marshall like song
poetry or some kind of dancing and folk
dance so that's cool though like we
don't have anything like that in
Australia I did folk dancing in school
really I didn't re like again like when
you're doing it in school you don't
think of it as weird now that I've grown
up I'm like okay that's weird we dress
up in these like kind of if you would
imagine I guess 1800s 1700s dresses
clothes and you just [ __ ] dance
around in circles and go in and out and
yeah it was I hated it but that but
that's so much cooler than like what we
like we only have like a singlet shirts
and thongs party and you listen to acpc
while drunk like that's the only culture
that we have
couches for fun but it's not exactly
like something you want it's probably
you don't go up to someone else and be
like hey do you know what we have in
Australia ACDC no because I definitely
like I've definitely like found more of
an appreciation of just culture growing
up because I remember a kid you'd be
forced to do all of these things you
know in your home country whatever
um and then you as a kid you're just
like why why do why do I do this why do
I want to do this this is weird I just
want to play video games and uh go home
and just talk to my friends on the
internet but I think like especially you
know
especially I'm like having a wedding as
well there's so many like traditions
around you know around having a wedding
right and some some of those Traditions
you don't even know what the origin of
that is like you know like taking a
piece of like taking a piece of jewelry
from you know the father-in-law or the
Mother-in-law we didn't do every
Tradition at our wedding but I know that
there are a lot of traditions with many
different cultures and many different is
there one where you like stomp on a wine
glass or something and Judaism oh
Judaism that's right yeah yeah yeah but
then I thought about it and I'm just
like damn like this this guy invented
probably a hundred years ago and like
your ancestors and your parents chose to
like keep this tradition going on so
basically you're like kind of taking
part in history and you might not even
know what that history is you don't even
know what that origin is but even just
by having this tradition uh even just by
doing this tradition you're like taking
part in like a lineage that you can't
even see the beginning of I'm like damn
that's and when I think about it like
that that's pretty damn can you when you
phrase it like that it's pretty funny
yeah yeah yeah so that's that's why I've
definitely grown more of an appreciation
of different world cultures and
different worldly activities which is
why I look at the Haka and I'm like damn
do I have any dude does my [ __ ] does my
Heritage have anything that cool because
I I want something that cool I'm sure
Thailand has something right like it
might not necessarily be like an
interpretive dance or whatever but I
know like a lot of Southeast Asian
countries have a lot of like I mean
there's a shitload of History yeah we
have like traditional Thai dancers
um but it's this I guess this is like
the downside of not growing up in this
Home Country which is I wasn't exposed
to a lot of this because I grew up in
England so I'd only see this I guess on
a like like tip of the ice on the tip of
the iceberg thing do you ever
um
think about you know there's some people
out there who you know when you say oh
you know I'm Thai and I'm this and this
and then they'll be like well I was born
and raised in Thailand you're not a real
Thai because you didn't you didn't grow
up there like I did well this is uh
actually this is uh well this is gonna
get into like a pretty deep conversation
because I've seen this comment not
towards you but towards other people
that have been thrown around a few times
without like well I I grew up there and
you didn't so you aren't part of I get
that a lot with Japan I imagine yeah
yeah so it's like how do you I mean well
okay no one's ever said that to me you
know no one said no one's ever said
you're not Thai and I think I would
probably get offended or something
because it's just incorrect yeah yeah
exactly uh hello if you look at my
bloodline I'm literally 100 Thai yeah
but it's it's a weird case because
because I didn't grow up in Thailand no
one would there will ever say that I'm
not Thai but it's kind of like the same
thing in Japan where there's this soft
boundary where you'll be treated a
little bit differently people will talk
to you bit differently and people will
view you a bit differently but on the
opposite and the side of things I I've
always been always viewed as an outsider
in England as well you know right I've
never felt like I've always felt like
okay my parents emigrated to England I
am I'm I'm a child of an immigrant
basically I'm a first uh first
generation but does that make me not
British no but does that mean that I had
a different kind of upbringing where I
acknowledged that I had a different
Heritage yeah and it's weird because
I've met kind of like a lot of Asian
Americans and they have like a totally
different view than I do right because
like I was I was having a conversation
with some Asian Americans and I was
asking them do you find it offensive if
people ask oh where are you from you
know because I don't find that offensive
because when when I when someone asked
me in England for example oh where are
you from I assume the context of that is
where is your heritage from where your
yeah you know but I think in America
some that's like a very much more
sensitive topic and sensitive question
because I've heard I've talked to plenty
of Asian Americans that would get very
offended if someone asked them where
they're from but like if you if you okay
I mean I shouldn't say something
if someone's Asian right yeah and you're
like oh what's like where in Asia are
you is like your your lineage your
bloodline I don't know whatever you want
to call it like where I that's something
like an interesting conversation to have
yeah and I I think the Nuance to that
question is that because a uh because
America is basically a country of
immigrants right you know um it's it's
kind of a like a slightly different
starting point
being uh and uh Asian British yes yeah I
guess I guess to be honest I think like
it's it's all about the Nuance because
it's like I yeah because I mean you ask
it yeah yeah exactly it's like no
because I remember there was one time in
America where like this American girl
asked me like oh where are you from yeah
and I said uh you know and I said I'm
from Australia yeah and then she said no
but where are you from yeah okay okay no
no okay yeah yeah I'm like are you
asking about my Heritage yeah uh if so
then then you could have just said
what's your background yeah you know so
I think it's all about the context right
right and it's like bloodline sounds
really fun what is your bloodline that
sounds badass
[ __ ] that makes it sound like it's a
[ __ ] narrative I'm gonna [ __ ]
Sharingan or some [ __ ] you know I'm from
the YouTube
all these DNA entry things are marketing
it way off yeah it's like you should
find out your bloodline it bought your
bloodline I have like some epic
narration you know do a DNA test in this
Vibe we need to start normalizing that
when you want to know where someone is
from just go what's your bloodline yeah
immediately you know what you're talking
about yeah none but like I mean I had
the exact same thing in Australia as
well yeah like you know because it's
like I'm not first generation because
only only half of me is but like you
know I still grew up with a lot of like
Japanese Traditions at home yeah so and
you know I don't look like your typical
Australian whatever a typical Australian
looks like so and I don't look like your
typical Japanese either so it's like I
in both countries I had this like
identity crisis of like what the [ __ ] am
I yeah because no one else around me
knows what I am until I specifically say
what I am yeah and then that made me
confused being like Oh am I Australian
or am I Japanese because that I mean now
I know I'm just like I'm just both like
yeah that's that's just what I say to
people same here but like now you know
but then that's why like I'm starting to
get a little bit like jaded when people
ask the where are you from question in
like a really [ __ ] nuanced way
because it's just like just I know what
you're trying to ask me just don't beat
around the [ __ ] you're not gonna
offend me by asking what my back
background because I I think I think a
big difference is uh to to these Asian
Americans I've talked to they are very
much okay I'm a proud American America
is my home America is my nationality you
know and and then they separate that
from okay I'm American and this is my
Heritage whereas I think of it as I'm
Thai and British you know it's it's
weird the trade-off I have for this is
that I don't really have a home country
you know because I've never felt I've
never felt so strongly in one camp or
the other I've actually just feel like
I'm in both but by being in both I've
never been I've never felt I've never
felt 100 accepted in either but I've
never felt a hundred percent home in
like either either yeah do you feel like
it's impossible for you to ever feel
like 100 British in a way yeah yeah I
mean I guess so but I I guess that's why
I've lived in so many different
countries because I don't really have an
attachment to one home country you know
that's that's why that's that's that's
the perception I've been given where I
find it so easy to move to a new country
or a new place because I'm like well I
don't really have any uh I I mean I I
feel like my Heritage is here but I
don't really have any ties personally
towards my feelings about this is my
home country or X is my home country
because to me anywhere can be my home
country you know am I wrong and say in
America isn't it like a big thing as
well for like uh a first uh first
generation immigrant parents to also
give their kids like very American
sounding names that's what I was about
to say I think it's like almost from my
understanding it's I don't know if how
common it is but from the people around
me that I know like uh kids with a you
know first generation immigrant parents
I think a lot of the parents almost
choose not to I guess feed their
children the their culture in America
because it's like they almost like kind
of oppress
their own culture towards their kids so
that they can like fit quote unquote fit
more with America because like I've
heard like a lot of my friends in
America who are you know first
generation Asian or whatever like
immigrant parents a lot of them can't
speak their parents all the time it's
quite normal it's quite normal I feel
it's quite normal in America though and
only in America for some reason it's no
I think it's pretty normal in the UK as
well in the UK yeah I know a lot of
people in the UK who
um who their parents made the decision
to not teach like they didn't it wasn't
even like laziness they like their
parents made the decision to not teach
their
um child their mother tongue right
because they wanted to be able to I
guess assimilate and see that's
fascinating because in Australia it's
the polar opposite right it's like
almost every Australian I know that has
immigrant parents yeah they can speak
their mother tongue to some level of
capacity and they're proud of it yeah
exactly well I think I think I don't
know why one thing that really surprised
me about Sydney and Australia is that
there are all it's so cultural yeah I
didn't realize it was this Multicultural
like I think when we were at Sydney uh
smash I was like they there are so many
Asian Australians and just you know a
lot of Southeast Asians and I'm like
damn I've never seen these this many
Southeast Asians in another country
since I was lost in Southeast Asia like
what the hell what the hell man yeah
yeah and it's like and again it's like
fascinating that because Australia is
such a multi-cultural country yeah and
and yet for some and and you know
America is as well I would say just as
much if not more than Australia yeah and
yet there is just this like almost polar
opposite dichotomy of teaching or
embracing your parents cultures yeah
that aren't American or aren't
Australian would you teach your kids
your second language or your first
language
because it's like if I'm not in that
country it makes no sense to teach them
that language
um it's just because of how how small
and very Niche the language it's not
like yeah hey I can I can take if it's
tie right oh hey I can take you to
Thailand you can use it it's like yeah I
can take you to Wales maybe we'll find
someone at one time you might be able to
you know what I mean yeah if you don't
live in that country yeah and also if I
didn't it's it's very it's my language
is it there's a lot of difficulties that
come with a dying language yeah uh and
preserving it right and when you're
outside of the country where they're
trying to preserve it it becomes like 20
times more difficult to preserve the
language it is it is and it takes
especially when if you want to teach
your kid a language that they don't use
in this country yeah it takes effort
because yeah it's it's part you know
it's like do you want to teach your kid
English in Japan easy do you want to
teach your kids Japanese in Australia
very doable do you want to teach your
kid any Asian language in London very
renewable it's like it depends on like
where you are and like if I was in Japan
the odds of me being able to be like hey
go go talk to all these other Welsh kids
it's like oh wait there are none okay I
don't because like the reason the reason
I ask this is because I've like I've
I've made the decision that I'm going to
teach my kid Thai as much as possible
even if they yeah I think it's a good
idea even if they never use it because
the thing is I can I the only person who
ever spoke Thai to me growing up was my
mum and because of this I I'm not like
100 100 fluent in time but if I really
want to go out of my weight and study it
like Joey has of Japanese I could I
could get fluent you know because the
base level is there yeah I just feel
like I want my kid to have the same
upbringing as me where I feel like the
reason I have such a big attachment to
Thailand even though I didn't actually
grow up there is because I can speak
Thai and I think just knowing that
language is such is such a big barrier
of Entry of just appreciating a culture
oh God just appreciating your heritage
right and I think if you don't know the
language you have to like you have to
work way harder to appreciate going to
this country and being like oh this is
uh this is where my parents are so it's
a really interesting point you raised
that because
again this happens again with dying
languages yeah what about like whales or
other countries in Europe where there
are languages that are you know
obviously English or another language is
taken over but there was a language
before yeah which was the the ones
connected to everything cultural and
historical yeah are you then if you're
not re if like let's say because there
are a lot of people in like Wales in
Scotland and Ireland for example who are
raised generations and generations of
Irish Scottish or Welsh were raised in
their country yeah and none of them ever
spoke
that the the language of the original
language yeah how would how would you
argue that that would affect then your
understanding of of the country's
culture in a sense
well I think that if you have if you
have this base level understanding of a
language even if it's dying out do you
how much of Welsh culture do you think
you understand more because you
understand Welsh right I mean playing
things like Elden ring and [ __ ] like
that seeing just a little pieces of
Welsh Welsh like native Welsh culture
everywhere I mean that's that's a cool
feeling right yeah yeah this I would say
it's you know you you can't ever be like
someone who's generations of families
raising country doesn't speak language
they're not they're not they don't
really understand that's that's not what
I'm saying yeah I know that yeah I know
at the end of the day I think like it's
just like if you're interested in it
regardless of how useful it is then you
know and you have an appreciation
towards it I don't think there's any
demerit in trying to learn it especially
at a young age when your brain is just a
sponge yeah exactly you know ingest
anything it's like you know like you
know you might not necessarily get say
in the case with Welsh for instance you
might not necessarily get a full on
understanding of the culture surrounding
it and anything but but at the end of
the day you can still say it's a cool
party trick at least you know at the end
of the day you can still say like I can
speak
[ __ ] Welsh yeah
but like
when it comes to a dying language right
yeah I still think it's a cool like if
you I would be impressed at anyone who
knows how to [ __ ] speak a dying
language yeah right because it's just
cool and it's like and I feel regardless
of how useful that language ends up
becoming you just naturally grow more of
an appreciation towards language towards
culture towards Linguistics of any
country yeah I also another fun Point
well not a fun fun point or a fun
question let's say there's a an American
historian who wants to learn about Welsh
culture or say Thai culture yeah
oh if you've never lived or grown up in
a country can you get a as good if not a
better understanding of a country's
culture through studying and reading and
whatnot because I'm sure there are a
bunch of people who are not from uh
Thailand or not from Wales I'm from
Australia who've studied it way more
than we ever even have considered it
yeah who probably have a deeper
historical cultural understanding of
your country than you do yeah they might
have a they might have a deeper
historical understanding but they may
not necessarily have a deeper modern
understanding of it yeah I was Modern
wise but then you could argue that some
countries lose a lot of their cultural
uh like values in the modern world so
it's weird because I I thought about
this and I was thinking well I have this
very specific understanding of my
culture but it only goes so far and I'm
wondering how biased is that like based
on the area I grew up or the people I
interacted with yeah yeah because I'm
thinking oh this culture's like this for
sure but then someone else from the
other side of country might have had a
completely different experience of the
culture yeah and I always wonder about
that kind of stuff and I'm like oh man
this is like a such a so even R so then
it makes me just think what is the
[ __ ] point of being arguing about who
knows more about a culture or what
experience is right about a culture it's
like it's like I feel like almost yeah I
mean uh there is no right experience no
I I know but it's like it's you you I
found that with sometimes people would
get an argument about what is the
correct thing of ex-culture yeah and I
always found it interesting where it's
like yeah you have to recognize that
culture is also biased oh absolutely it
is culture is is even historical
accounts of culture are somewhat biased
yeah yeah so it's like it's just such a
worm's nest of and then this all comes
back to the whole point the initial
thing I brought up of
people being like you don't know the
culture and it's like well it's like no
you've had your experience with the
culture yeah this is such a whole
rabbit's nest and and it all came from
this one comment that pissed me off
I saw this one comment and it pissed me
off because I was like [ __ ] you
um that was uh someone argued he was
like well I don't think God is Welsh
because he he left the moment he could
and his dad is English so [ __ ] him he's
not Welsh it's like well [ __ ] you I grew
up in the culture country for 19 years I
speak the language my mom is Welsh but I
don't even I don't even think I need
Welsh parents to be Welsh if I'm born in
a country and I'm raised there and I
speak the goddamn language I think
you're the [ __ ] of that country like
yeah yeah what are you talking about and
it's like did this dude just wake up
today and just feel like he wanted to
feel better than me I am the alpha Welsh
[ __ ] you you are merely the beta well
I'm like do you have do you have to stay
in a country to be like the moment you
leave America if you've lived there for
20 years you're not American anymore are
you [ __ ]
imagine wanting to then broaden your
horizons and experience another world
yeah yeah God forbid you want to
experience another culture I mean I mean
not all culture will stay the same our
experiences are going to change I mean I
don't know maybe you know you go back to
England and the Tesco meal deal is no
longer the price it was you're just like
okay I was talking [ __ ] on trash tastes
okay
it's not cheaper some more okay but I
mean yeah yeah
but like I I think especially in terms
of like understanding culture it's when
you have you found that when you go back
to your home country or place you
haven't visited for a long time your
personality also like subtly shifts to
what it was like before you moved out oh
it doesn't even subtly shift it in like
full-on [ __ ] it's like people were
telling me my sister was telling me
while I was in Australia yeah the past
you know two and a half weeks that every
other day that she saw me she was like
your accent's getting sicker yeah yeah
and I was like is it because to me it
just sounds like the same I noticed my
accent getting like my British accent
like getting way way thicker just going
back yeah the frequency of in it was
definitely increasing
way more American I feel like I feel
like I got more American oh yeah yeah
you definitely yeah I was definitely in
America yeah oh yeah yeah no I mean
you're 100 you're influenced by you know
the people around you're surrounding
with regardless of which country you're
in it's like that um there was a study I
think they did in the uh one of the uh
stations where they are [ __ ]
Antarctica what are those remote [ __ ]
places where there's snow Antarctica one
of the one of them what are the [ __ ]
places I don't know they're so goddamn
Island they did a study because
obviously a lot of the times they're
they're scientists from different
countries all shoved into one place and
a common where it was this is very
anecdotal don't take this as in like uh
all different countries I think after uh
weeks of them all staying together like
one of the accents became like the more
dominant and a lot of the other actions
were starting to kind of shift towards I
think it was German in this study it was
slowly started becoming towards like a
more German accent weirdly you'd think
maybe it'd be American or something yeah
and yeah it was just kind of interesting
the German guy spoke the most yeah maybe
it's just go like you are a hundred
percent 100 influenced by accents around
you oh absolutely well your action will
change yeah yeah depending on where
you're staying and it's not like a how
dare you you've forgotten your home
accent Connor you'll [ __ ] it's like no
it's just how
everyone works that way we want a copy
because that's we're animals and we're
social animals and we're designed Yeah
by [ __ ] Darwin I guess he decided
that all uh that we're gonna fit it
thank God
for the Darwin patchness we were Alphas
we would remain this well you know you
know why we're we're [ __ ] we're we're
herbivores and betas is because we we
need other people's validation yeah so
that's why do I sound okay our whole
brain is designed that we need to fit in
we've got to fit in yeah that's why
sigmas exist like me who don't want to
fit in no I mean take my course right
now 100. this is what we call a
herbivore in denial
no I I I I I I'm cripplingly in need
everyone's attention
do you know one of the stupidest [ __ ]
like uh one of the stupidest trends that
you know this whole Alpha movement of
like how to tell you I didn't go to
Alpha con is that a real thing
but but one thing I've actually yeah
yeah it is as bad as you think it is
yeah the post is just like a bunch of
white dudes I can't remember who told me
about alphagon I don't think it was you
I told you did you tell me about it you
should look at the poster for it yeah
I'll look at the poster for it hold on
yeah it's uh it's when you look at
photos and you see a girl and the guy
and you and there are like people that
are breaking down the angle that I like
these things the guys leaning in it's
like if you lean in you're the beta yeah
oh yeah oh [ __ ] way this is real yeah
that's real what the [ __ ] alphacon 2022
be great or be nothing
what a [ __ ] tagline dude that's just
like men in denial the convention just
admit that you're all right this is just
Macho insecurity the convention it is it
was like a scam oh my God
yeah I love that angle thing yeah it's
like the beta leans in
the woman better lean into the man or
the man's baby
sometimes like a random picture will
show up in my timeline of just a guy and
you see like the the angles like it's a
red line of the guy being like okay he's
he's standing up with this he should be
standing up in an upright position but
he's at a he's at a 80 degree angle the
woman is not bending he's bending the
woman he's a beta and I'm like maybe why
would they not just change this to
misogynist and I'm just like maybe the
guy's just tall I don't know maybe he's
tired
okay I get it Alphas don't get tired
they just don't
oh my God I can't believe that's real
this episode of trash taste is sponsored
by PC specialist happy Halloween from PC
specialist guys
the next generation of PC gaming is now
here ladies and gentlemen with the
latest Hardware releases from Intel AMD
and Nvidia not confident in building a
PC yourself Jerry PC specialist offers a
competitive pricing and range of options
to build your dream PC whether you're a
gamer me Enthusiast or content creator
all of us or a professional we're trying
to be PC specialist caters to your needs
they're easy to use configuration allows
you to customize each component of your
build to your desire guys can you
believe that each PC is meticulously
cable managed I know guys I know what
does that mean what does that mean I
don't even know for that clean aesthetic
and then thoroughly tested to ensure
stability and performance and guess what
guys all of their PCS are powered by
Windows 11. playtime anytime for a
limited time only during the Halloween
period you can get a larger discount
after next purchase exclusive to trash
taste listeners by using the link in
description down below and using Code
trash at the checkout take it to PC
specialist for the sponsor back to the
show fellow herbivores rise up
before
it's not just vegetarians huh I'm just
vegetarian you just describe vegetarians
yes it comes from a Japanese term what
social herbivore social care
yeah it literally means herbivore what
like guys like social care means like uh
like guys who are not like they're very
docile and like not aggressive and
they're always like ladies first type of
thing and they're like never they never
Advance on girls and stuff like that and
they in Japan they called herbivores
okay
I'm sorry I got the word from because I
[ __ ] love that term
I don't know why herbivore just sounds
so fun it's such a perfect time
literally Wikipedia when you put social
cookies I've heard before men yeah
herbivore man yeah yeah before men well
I think that's because like Japan I
don't know like how how deep into like
vegetarian culture and vegan culture is
Japan in right now because I remember
when we moved here there wasn't really
much I think five years ago is like
nothing right yeah vegan maybe
vegetarian I think it's vegetarian might
have been like one in a hundred
restaurants in Tokyo maybe but like yeah
I definitely think like now yeah since
the pandemic I think and even like a
little bit before that as well like I
did start to notice a lot of vegan
places as well as like vegan and
vegetarian like now there's it's not
infrequent to see menus that have like
the vegetarian symbol or like the vegan
symbol or something there's a few really
good vegan I go to actually quite a fair
amount of vegan places
I'm not even like vegan I don't care I
just think that like sometimes I just
want food that isn't gross feeling and
vegan food is normally like really clean
there's a vegan ramen place I know uh I
think in Tokyo it's it's a change
or something something like that
something they do they do like uh cognac
yeah yeah noodles it's actually really
good I hate Kanye yeah I hate kanyaku I
think it's [ __ ] yeah it's disgusting
yeah and I don't stand for it yeah but
the noodles are pretty decent actually
because I accidentally ordered it and I
I I was like I hate konyaku and normally
because you get it in like some soups
and you get it in like a lot of hot pots
yeah yeah and it's it's like a potato
but [ __ ] yeah and I normally just it's
like a gelatinous potato it's like slimy
potato it's so gross but the noodle is
actually really good because it was like
not slimy it was just kind of like a
little a little chewy but it's good it's
like the thin cognac yeah so if you want
Ramen it's a given it doesn't taste like
normal Ramen but Ramen that is very low
calorie and pretty healthy for you you
can get a vegan I was yeah I was
pleasantly surprised by it yeah because
I I went to it because one of my friends
uh is a vegetarian yeah I I think we're
talking about the same let me get the
place here we can recommend it yeah yeah
I went there because I was with one of
my vegetarian friends we couldn't find
any other like vegetarian place so we
just like oh let's just go to this like
the food place
um yeah and I went and I was like oh I
wonder because you know like a lot of
ramen is the polar opposite of vegan or
vegetarian right yeah yeah it's just
like it's very oily very you know it's
meat broth based and stuff like that so
I thought like it's gonna be this is
gonna be like the featheriest [ __ ]
Ramen ever with like no substance
whatsoever but it was it surprisingly
fills you up and it's and and again it
like it's Ramen without the gross
feeling it's it's Ramen without the food
coma yeah basically um yeah so it's I I
think they did um they're like weird
broths as well I think the one I had was
spicy yusu spicy
spicy nice very refreshing very
refreshing I know there's vegan burger
places yeah that are apparently very
good never been like impossible burgers
and stuff yeah they're probably really
good um I know there's um a bunch of uh
vegan cafes so many of them right
um that are really good there's a few in
uh Shinjuku that I know that already and
there are like some just like
traditional Japanese Foods as well that
are technically vegan but I don't think
until recently were labeled as vegan
yeah so I think it's just like the fact
that this is obviously before the
pandemic but like when a lot more
foreigners were coming over and
obviously with that there's a higher
population of vegans and vegetarians
outside of Japan because it's not really
a thing in Japan
um and you know I guess like a lot of
restaurants like oh there's a there's a
lot of these vegetarian and vegan people
that are coming to this country we
should probably cater towards them
especially since the Olympics are coming
up I wonder how they're doing after the
pandemic yeah right silver lining of the
vegan places they normally always have
English menus yeah yeah that's true
which you know I don't need an English
menu all the time but it is just nice to
have sometimes you're just like ah [ __ ]
yeah I did I didn't want to read today
this is good
I just think yeah yeah some really good
options now in Tokyo but I think the
reason why a lot of places get held back
from being vegan is eggs and stuff yes
Eggs oh yeah so much stuff with that
that's true a lot of stuff with eggs a
lot of stuff with uh fish and stuff like
that fish oils yeah fish sauce like a
lot of like uh you know like uh animal
bone broths and stuff like that's very
common yeah when's Yuzu going to be more
popularized around the world okay it's
too much
oh my God I like YouTube
let me I like YouTube I like YouTube let
me preface okay because I was I was a
clown when I first oh my God okay you're
still a clown no no you are still a
clown I'm less of a clown no
I I took the hit off just a little part
of me as well I took one of the shoes
off and it only squeaks my when I
replace them with a messy Italy squeaks
my take one of the steps now does it
does it mean if I picked like a Twitter
meme like a reply image that's just
someone putting on clown shoes yeah it's
gone getting ready for work just the
shoes
we give the [ __ ] clown shoes to each
other every week
yeah but like when I first moved to
Japan I'd never had for some reason I'd
never heard of Yuzu before had you heard
of Uzi before well it's a very Japanese
foreign
what it looks like an orange more than
I'm like a hybrid between orange it's
like a lemon and an orange put together
for those you don't yeah yeah I mean I I
mean I Look to that never like I I
thought I thought my brain went uh
usually must just mean lemon when you
take one look at a user you're just like
wow that's a big lemon yeah exactly
that's what I thought okay because at
least with limes limes different
completely different color but you know
there are like some Japanese like fruits
and vegetables that have the same name
but like what other fruit is yellow what
other fruit is yellow that's shaped like
that yeah exactly that's that's that
that was what I was thinking there's no
other fruit I know that's yellow in my
mind aside from lemon so I was like
great it's a lemon so I didn't know that
Yuzu and lemons were a completely
different thing yeah so I was and and
Sydney was just like how could you be so
[ __ ] dumb this is obviously a lemon
this isn't museums like what's what's
the difference what's so great about
using I don't get it but like now that
I've lived in Japan for two years
usually [ __ ] slaps man Yuzu is like
STS Citrus citrus fruit yeah a
[Music]
Mexican Mexican Brothers rise up lime is
the best put it on everything lime has
always been the beta lemon like it's
it's been it's been like it's been like
the [ __ ] no it's been the but you know
it's the exciting lemon oh my okay okay
we're not having this argument yeah okay
okay so here's my thing with Yuzu I
think it's great it's got an amazing
flavor but you put it in anything you
cannot taste anything else except for
Yuzu it [ __ ] takes over everything
and you can't deny this it does well
what's wrong with that when it tastes
good because like some dishes they're
like it's it's usually hint of Yuzu and
you're like all right you taste it
you're like I just tasted YouTube and
it's like I don't want people to start
putting Yuzu in everything because it as
a dominant flavor it [ __ ] sucks
it it doesn't suck as a dominant flavor
I [ __ ] I [ __ ] love you oh
so when you get like a uh sometimes you
get like a little like sprinkle little
user in it and then it's like now all I
can take is user and the same with food
they sprinkle a bit of Yuzu on it and
all I can taste is use it and I'm like
I'm so just why it's like bacon on the
burgers you bite into a burger with a
bacon in it and it just tastes like
bacon so yusu is not as potential
what are you on but like it's got such a
unique like it's got such a unique
flavor product I agree that's what I
love about it it's good there's not many
things in the world that you know I
don't want to take out that tastes like
music because like the thing about Yuzu
ponzu is oh my Lord oh like the thing
about Yuzu is that it it always tastes
like Yuzu
flavor to the audience I don't even know
it's it's like the only way I can
describe someone described it to me once
as eating a lemon and an orange together
but like even then it's like it's hard
like that's probably the closest but
like it feels like a vinegary lemon
vinegar is way more overpowering you
know like if you added a dash of vinegar
to Lemon that's how I would imagine it's
kind of like a very like bitter-ish kind
of uh line okay wait wait how would you
describe limes then
I just made a lemons
more more tasteful lemon
but the lemon with a bit of that's
that's but that's why I like that's why
Yuzu is just so [ __ ] good because it
has such a Google how does Google
describe such a distinct flavor profile
in terms like the citrus fruits because
like you know you take you take let's
say a lemon and a lime and yes there is
a difference in flavor but it's not
massive you know yeah you know I'm sure
a lot of people wouldn't even be able to
taste the difference between a lemon and
a lime you know uh same thing would say
you know orange and tangerines or
clementines there is a there is a
difference you know in the in their
flavor profiles but it's not massive
yeah and I feel like Yuzu has such a
distinct nothing else tastes like you
yeah nothing else tastes like Yuzu and
it tastes I mean subjective how amazing
it tastes so everyone seems to agree
that it's a hybrid of uh either lemon
lime and a bit of grapefruit which I
would kind of say oh yeah yeah yeah
you're gonna take a sip again fruit and
amazing oh like for a second or you're
like oh it's like a sweet it's like a
sweet it's it's got the good properties
of grapefruit without the law yeah
afterwards okay
grapefruit is the worst citrus fruit it
is okay I will agree on that I kind of
like grapefruit
I used to hate it would you okay
grapefruit is one sit for you just
cannot have by yourself oh no no I can't
have a bite so that that that's cheating
that makes it an awful [ __ ] citrus
fruit because if you need something else
well you gotta have lemon juice by
itself I can it's actually like you know
no doubt without any thinners 100 lemon
juice
if I got a full-on lemon right now cut
it in half squeeze all of it bone dry
into a glass and gave it to you would
you be able to finish yo I only have my
lemon butter
if you if you gave it to me all in the
glass I would prefer the lemon juice
over the grape juice
yeah grape juice is wine
here sorry grapefruit juice yeah yeah I
would prefer it really yeah but yes I
would I would I mean I think grapefruit
is like every worst citrus fruit flavor
profile just in one and the only thing
that offsets that is having like some
sugar or something with it but do you
like better things yeah yes a lot better
things so then why don't you like
grapefruit
just no because it's like it's just it's
bitter doesn't mean that we're gonna
like it yeah it also just tastes bad and
then it's better like it just tastes bad
I'm not saying it's the best tasting
fruit in the world
I'm saying it's the worst tasting food
really it's one of them it's definitely
it's definitely down Nigerians okay well
durians is in no during [ __ ] slab
starts that slush is in the carry but I
don't even count that as fruit that's
just like that's just it is literally
called the king of Fert
something went wrong with it look it up
who called it that it's everyone calls
it that no everyone is wrong
you can wear your crown of durians if
you want because I I ain't wearing my
crowns a rotting dead corpse on a plane
and a durian airport security would ask
me to throw away the durian yeah
that is it's equivalent I don't see
shine saying humping on a dead body as
as someone who's been in Thailand I've
been to stores I don't know if I've told
this story on the podcast maybe it
happened I'll repeat it just in case
I've seen Thailand's like I've been to
places in Thailand I've seen stores and
places that have a sign that says you
are not allowed to bring guns in this
place and also along with guns no durian
so in in some places in Thailand guns
are in the same level as durian somehow
I could get that I can get that I mean
it tastes good but it definitely smells
like [ __ ] that's for sure like until it
touches your tongue you just your brain
is just like am I eating a turd right
now and then the moment it touches your
tongue you're like okay it's not what to
do it yeah this is this is this is why I
will never be truly seen as time
this is the real reason he's not a real
type he doesn't like durian that's the
real reason why they don't see me as one
of them you're a great big friend it's
like oh you can speak our language you
do you like it but can you eat durian
yeah it's like it's like an undercover
cop who just refuses to try drugs you
know it's just like oh oh you're clearly
a pig of course of course you're not one
of us oh my God one thing that surprises
me is that I'm calling it out Yuzu is
going to be the next big fad I'm
surprised it's still not yet I'm
surprised as well it's it's because this
because this is in America in California
you know yeah this like if this if if
there's a fruit that screams privileged
California it's using yo get it's like
it's going to be the next [ __ ]
Starbucks infused flavor I swear to God
I'm like yeah use Duty in California
using cold tea honestly that's that's
really [ __ ] good you know what's a
mid flavor and it is just like not good
soccer yeah
Sakura just doesn't taste good like you
can't change I don't know anyone who
actually thinks Sakura is an amazing
flavor right they just love the theming
that's it everyone just it just looks
good I was like oh cherry blossoms oh
yeah Sakura doesn't taste like and then
you drink the [ __ ] the Frappuccino or
some [ __ ] from Starbucks you're like
just use a [ __ ] actual flavor yeah
wait we're talking like Sakura flavored
or like ume flavored uh Sakura flavor
right do you like ume flavored stuff
UMES like Plum I I mean I love umeshu
Yeah and everything else we may is kind
of meh well the thing about Sakura is
that the trees just marketed themselves
perfectly they're just like we're gonna
Bloom for like one time in the year and
you've only got a few [ __ ] days
there's your scarcity guys all right
scarcity yeah scarcity scarcity
soccer is literally the hype Beast of
flowers
[Applause]
that's literally
drop of flowers
I love it
yeah but is there a reason why we
haven't genetically modified the sakura
tree to grow all year round or have we
scarcity man it's all marketing
marketing I know I'm sure they could I'm
sure they could I don't know I think I
think maybe it's because Japanese the
Japanese probably see it like
historically they probably see it as
like uh the the scarcity is like a very
like Poetic thing yeah you know because
like it's it's been like that for sure
poetic [ __ ] thousand yeah it's like
oh you know it's beautiful it's like
it's like a firework it's only momentary
but while it's there it is the most
beautiful thing of the planet is there
any uh sakura trees that have been
genetically modified to bloom all year
round car can you well I know I know
perfect that all Sakura trees in Japan
are all clones of each other like as in
as in the trees and that's why they all
bloom all at the same time sure yes I'm
100 agree that there is an alpha Sakura
Alpha they literally all share the same
brain surely now maybe they're
descendants they all can't be the same
otherwise like one pest would will kill
them all well yeah is that really true
I'm fairly certain and that's that's the
reasons are why they all bloom all at
the same time and then they all fall all
at the same time as well give us an
answer
do it all year round but then being able
to do it again
oh so they have been trying
because they've been trying so they can
do it to bloom in Autumn I actually
would be sick are you kidding I would
not want to go Hannah me in Autumn why
not oh sorry Autumn I thought you said
August oh yeah I was like August
could you imagine what it's all like you
know really red and yellow and this
[ __ ] [ __ ] do that okay yeah that'd be
sick I'm sure like I'll be I I I'd laugh
if there's like a sakura tree committee
that just goes around like [ __ ]
breaking every science project that
tries to attempt that seems very on
brand for you oh no no if if Japan is
full of one thing it's Puritans yeah
they love they love they love they're
just like no don't tamper with the
thousands of
your dream it's like and
then but it's pretty yeah
then people will realize that Sakura
tasting stuff and then Starbucks comes
around the corners like that'll make
some dough again baby let's go do a fact
check on the old cherry blossoms are the
same yeah all cherry blossoms are the
same
yeah they're all replicated yeah but
that's yeah I I remember I saw that on
like a bunch of different Japanese sites
so I I know that for certain and like TV
and stuff I don't know how they did it
but
makes sense did you see that um the uh
amount of weddings had dropped like
massively because of covid in Japan yep
really yeah oh and then people were
freaking the government was like for
[ __ ] sake we're already having a hard
time getting goddamn babies we didn't
need people not getting married and
[ __ ] for two years this is awful wait
wait people not getting married or
people not having weddings well people
don't have well because you can get
married in Japan but not have a wedding
oh well I'm getting married oh getting
married going out a meeting yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah people weren't going out
people weren't going to bars to meet
their co-workers they eventually fall in
love with have two babies good yay
government likes that yeah so now
they're like for [ __ ] sake what is
happening now how do we get people to go
out because people now people even even
though you can go out and Yeah and have
a fun time and there's still a lot of
people who aren't going out yeah um so
now Japan has another battle it's like
now we've got to get them to go out one
reason YouTubers I'm just kidding
the YouTuber apocalypse
all right I told you I was wrong that's
not [ __ ] true no Everyone's Watching
YouTubers yeah well but I mean
I mean do not say that that is a mass
part of it though no no no I mean
yeah
as as someone who used to watch a lot of
YouTubers I would say I think a global
pandemic was a much bigger Factor but I
mean like yeah I'm not saying it's the
number one reason facials they're made
YouTubers show me Japan not have babies
I never said that was the number one
reason I'm aware that there was a
pandemic
I didn't come out of a rock and be like
damn btube is really [ __ ] ruined
alone
I'll never forget that I'll never
forgive the YouTubers
what are you what are you okay as as
this is fun this is a fun little thing
okay so okay your Japanese doesn't count
what do you what you can do there from
The Foreigner perspective how do you
think Japan has to fix their their not
having babies in one simple solution not
immigration because they're never gonna
do it
you know you knew what I was about
because literally because it was the
obvious song
they're like oh hey Japan you know
there's this really easy cheat effects
that will solve your uh your your
declining uh population right yeah and
they're like oh what is it they're like
I'll just let immigrants in all right no
what is it they're just like did you
know there's a lot of people outside
Japan that yeah really want to [ __ ]
Japanese people
you know I mean yellow fever is kind of
a thing just saying he could say that
one it's just like he's the only one
album
Japanese people kind of hot I wouldn't
be here so I think I have the Liberty to
say that is your dad like into Japanese
women is that like why or is it just oh
yeah no he was like I went to Japan one
time and I got yellow fever
the man took what he wanted
I thought he wanted that's why though
they're breaking my mind bro that's why
though there are so many hafus out there
because because my dad isn't the only
one so Japanese people are hot Japan has
made it very clear that they do like
because they that solution has been
proposed yeah
to them many times of course yeah and
they've constantly been like we'll find
them that way it's like yeah but what's
the real organism initially it was like
we'll just make robots
and like turns out that robot technology
is like you know because they've been
making these robots since like the 90s
like companion robots yeah it's like the
90s and they just don't [ __ ] work
like they don't they don't solve a
problem and they it's been shown in
downtown again this is not going to
happen anytime soon yeah so you need to
think of something else so they're
they're I I literally can't think of a
word you know what's interesting
actually just I think they're [ __ ]
like I think they're down until they let
immigrants in yeah the the problems no
no I was going to say like
coincidentally I started watching uh
this show on Netflix Called Love is
Blind do you know the show yeah yeah
yeah yeah the Japanese one have you seen
the Japanese I've seen that I've seen
the Japanese one it's like not gonna I'm
a fan now what do you like about it it's
just like okay so here's the thing I I
watched back to back the American
version of love is blind and then I
watched the Japanese version of Love
explain all right yeah so explain the
show love is blind is this is this TV
reality show where uh a bunch of guys
and a bunch of girls who are looking for
love come uh they
they all come to these like this house
and and the males are separated with the
females and basically you go into what
they call pods basically and you talk to
if you're a guy you talk to a bunch of
girls and if you're a girl you talk to
all the guys yeah but you never see
their face until you propose
very very radical show right so you go
from not seeing each other to propose it
and so it's basically the whole concept
is you don't fall in love with the
person because of how they look you fall
in love with the person because of who
they are on the inside so what's the key
difference between the American big key
difference right watching the Japanese
one is like watching the best [ __ ]
romance anime you'll ever see because
it's so it is 100 just wholesome [ __ ] at
the moment the moment the doors open and
this guy and girl who has fallen in love
with each other's personalities see each
other for the first time and they're
just like like it just lights up and
they you know like awkwardly hug and
[ __ ] like that it's like oh now we're a
husband and wife it's so [ __ ]
wholesome yeah the one American episode
I watched this [ __ ] clearly this guy
just came back from alphacon because
[ __ ] walks up and just like grabs the
girl's ass and is like I can't wait to
get in that ass
I'm just like I was like oh my [ __ ] my
[ __ ] God you
and has just completely ruined this
building this is why every romance anime
ends when they kiss yeah right this is
why they never go farther in romance
anime yeah and then in every American
rom-com they go to the [ __ ] yeah and
uh it's just like so like when I saw
that I was just like that might be a
good thing because I feel and this is
just completely from how I see it I
think a big problem with Japanese dating
culture is that the Japanese Society has
kind of and especially a lot of like TV
and media has kind of built up this
weird stigma around how someone looks
right because like the the the the you
know the whole thing of like how
Japanese people need to be like really
skinny and like you know very fashion
oriented they all need to look like
pretty and stuff like that it's all a
lot of like outside right walks right
which you know if anyone has ever dated
anyone would know that can only get you
so far yeah right and I think because
but you know for a lot of people the
first step to finding a partner yeah is
you know unfortunately for a lot of
people it's like if you're not hot then
I don't even want to try kind of thing
and I feel that mentality that toxic
mentality is really sunken in deep in
Japan yeah because of things like Idol
culture because of the High fashion
standards because of the high you know
like just high standards the soy boys
the soy boys basically I just think like
it's like I was trying to say like the
problem is so deep rooted that you can't
just point to one thing of course like
like the first barrier I think of is
that uh where do people find time to
meet people that's the other thing yeah
I'm not just that's just one of the
barriers because well people are gonna
have to find time out of their work so
the first thing you're gonna have to fix
like one of the things you're going to
fix is just the overworked culture in
Japan because no one [ __ ] has time to
meet people here
um and then on top of that there's like
seven different other barriers yeah that
are just within the Japanese Society
there you have to go past them
unfortunately making one anime about a
dad and a cute daughter is not gonna
[ __ ] fix all that you know like like
you know you can make [ __ ] 10 spikes
families but that's not gonna fix the
underlying problem unfortunately yeah I
find depressing that like they think of
every other solution except like like
the obvious one yeah they just they
always just do it like you know make a
robot loves you instead or you know go
make a call line where you can just call
someone to love you or go to a host club
and talk to a girl it's like literally
like they they just it's I I'm just
baffling that
even though the lengths like the whole
rent of family things right even that
that's an extension of that it's like it
it just perplexes me how they will
explore every Avenue that is not just
like hey just let people have like an
extra hour off work like let them let
them try and meet people or hey maybe as
uh maybe when they're kids we should
maybe focus on uh making them be like
have social skills or yeah talking more
instead of ramming exams that are down
their throat to death I think with the
kind of change you would need to do this
it's kind of like a generation oh oh
dude like way more than that I think I
think it's like multiple Generations I
think at this one it is probably it's
just a cultural thing because yeah it is
like a lot of this is not because like a
lot of this is ingrained within Japanese
culture it's not the in Japanese culture
to you know not find a partner but a lot
of the of the effects I've seen within
Japanese culture this is one of the
results of that you know yeah
um yeah that's uh that's a whole [ __ ]
web to untangle and I wouldn't even know
where to begin with that aside from just
let's just uh let more people come in
the country yeah it's it's fairly simple
Japan is just full of a bunch of
herbivores right so let the carnival
foreigners come in and just take them to
town
did you let the alphas come in dude
there's not enough Alphas in this
country another interesting thing about
that I read online apparently now
because a lot of kids in Japan yeah have
had to wear masks for the pandemic
apparently there's like you know they've
been forced to wear masks like a lot of
kids now that are like 10 12 13 Japan
that are really young yeah don't feel
comfortable taking off their mask at any
point yeah right so they never take off
their mask yeah yeah
um and it's a it's an extension of also
like being shy and it makes you know
more timid but also there's really
interesting thing that they pointed out
where being like when you're growing up
apparently something for Social
Development like your brain is it not
seeing people's faces all the time is
apparently quite detrimental to your uh
your I believe that yeah and so if
you're just all the other kids are all
wearing masks it's like this is kind of
bizarre yeah everyone just looks like an
NPC yeah and it's also a lot of kids
have reported that they just like they
feel very uncomfortable and like shy and
just not great without wearing a mask
yeah yeah and that's just like whoa
that's I mean as if we needed any more
problems bizarre I mean even even me
like even just like the two years we've
gone through the pandemic going abroad
and seeing people not wearing masks I'm
like oh yeah that's what a human face
looks like that's what a chin looks like
that's what mouth movement looks like
when people are talking oh I forgot like
obviously mass culture has been big but
not to this understand oh no no I don't
think kids ever really wore mass in
Japan but like in school before no they
did yeah but like not only when they
were sick there right yeah only maybe
maybe during like influenza season right
right it wasn't an all year round thing
no it's like it's like some kids chose
to wear masks all year round just
because it makes them feel more
comfortable but it wasn't like a society
it was interesting as well in this thing
there was like there was a anecdotal or
I don't know reports of like certain PE
teachers that had to like they were like
like shouting at kids like hey take off
your mask or during P like you're not
gonna breathe outside properly yeah yeah
yeah you better like you can he it's
like 40 degrees yeah take it off and
they were like apparently they were like
just so uncomfortable with the idea that
they wouldn't take it off I mean I don't
blame them because even I felt
uncomfortable taking my mask off when we
first went to England and saw everyone
not wearing a mask you know and that's
me having lived most my life you know
the moment you start running though yeah
yeah that's right at the moment I'm even
getting remotely physical bro I want to
rip that oh absolutely are you kidding
me yeah there's nothing worse than
[ __ ] exhaling and having to breathe
in your own just exhale yeah but he felt
guilty for like feeling that way right
no I mean I'm gonna take off my Max I
know like in the gym you know if if you
needed to take off your mask right I
felt even though I know even though I
knew like of course I'm gonna need to
take my mask off at the gym no there
were there were still some gyms deep
during the pandemic or even like after
not even deeply pandemic that you know
didn't allow you to take off my gym
still says to not wear masks but a lot
of people don't wear the masks in the
gym yeah um I I know there's some gyms
where they've banned masks in Japan
really yeah
right right well I know I definitely can
see that especially recently ever since
we got back like definitely it seems to
getting started getting a little more
relaxed when it comes to Mars like I've
seen every time I've gone into a corn
mini there's at least one person I think
we want to preface we're not like that
kind of group of uh empty maskers no no
you take that freaking muzzle off your
face son like I'm not like that like I
just you know I think that as the
pandemic is easing and as as the
temperature is like 40 [ __ ] degrees
outside yeah
take I'm like I don't want to wear this
[ __ ] thing it's and it's crazy
because the government has said like
don't wear the mask outside if you're if
you know you're feeling a little woozy
and like yeah don't worry about wearing
a mask outside but everyone is still
wearing a mask outside here yeah it's
crazy because it's because even if the
government says that people look around
and it's just like that's the thing
though right are you gonna do it it's a
problem with the collective assistant
it's a Mexican standoff right everyone
is like I think it's like it was
something uh uh there was some surveys I
read about because I was really I got
really interested in this because then I
started thinking like when is this ever
going to stop like is this ever gonna
end I don't think it is no like it's
there was it was like 40 of people want
to wear masks and want others to wear
masks and the rest were kind of
different variations between like I I'll
wear a mask but I don't care if anyone
else does and I don't want to wear a
mask and I don't want anyone else to
wear a mask it was like it was like 40
to 60 but everyone's still wearing them
even though like 40 to 60 of people
don't want to wear a mask well no no no
that's that's 40 40 to me is the
majority because that's 40 minutes
saying yeah 40 is the majority in just
one of those options right where
everyone else might be on the fence but
if you're on the fence and you see 40
people 40 of people wearing masks you're
gonna wear them that's what I'm saying
is that like it and again because like
you said Japan is a collection of
collective collect collect activists
collectivist Society you know everyone
follows what everyone else is doing yeah
so it's like people want like a lot of
people don't want to wear it but then no
one wants to be the first one to take it
off yeah and then when they see someone
that's not wearing it they're like wow
what a [ __ ] delinquent yeah and it's
just like oh of course it's the foreign
when they tell me to do it because I'm
I'm not I'm not an [ __ ] because I
don't I I you know because I don't want
to be an [ __ ] to everyone I don't
want it yeah because it's like it's like
okay if I'm like on a train like public
transport full of people in Pro in close
proximity yeah I'll wear a mask right
because you know it's it's going to make
other people uncomfortable and I'm in an
air conditioned room so whatever but
like I've recently like every time every
time I get off my local train station
right because it's a smaller train
station with not that many people on my
way home which is like a five minute
walk I take my mask off yeah there isn't
people around right and if there are
people it's scarce enough where I'm not
going to be in close proximity with
anyone and yet I still get weird looks
from the one guy that walks past me
being like wow I can't believe you're
not wearing a mask I'm like bro the
closest human being other than you is
[ __ ] 200 meters away I think he's I
think he's fine but that's why you're a
herbivore man you just like if you're in
that if you're an alpha you wouldn't
care what I understand I don't care what
other people think you wouldn't if I
cared then I would be wearing masks all
the time I'd be wearing a mask right now
there are more people I've noticed that
aren't wearing masks but I think it's
just so great it's very very slowly it's
like everything in Japan it's is like
one of the few countries that had a mask
culture before the pandemics yeah of
course yeah but it was more seasonal
like I remember not in the summer it was
like people did not wear masks in the
South no yeah I I just remember that it
was like you would see it but it was
nowhere near like no never but the ones
wearing the masks were the weird ones
yeah but I feel I feel like if there's
one country that can that I can see just
persisting this behavior and one country
that would be I guess comfortable with
even wearing masks deep in the summer
it's it's Japan I mean like I don't even
know how people are walking around in
business suits in this [ __ ] heat you
know and like I look at people like that
I'm like how do you survive the winter
it's like how are you not like how do
you not have frostbite during the winter
yeah just it's not I don't think any
it's going to change for a while as well
just because like all the all the
[ __ ] politicians here or they all
just appeal to old people yes of course
because it's the voting population yeah
it's like you can't lose your elderly
voters so you know it's never going to
change because everything in Japan is
controlled by old people yeah that's why
that's why the board is still close
there's nothing in this country is is
even remotely catered to anyone under
the age of 40. yeah which is so sad and
that's because they don't teach the
importance of that to young people yeah
and it's not and it's not I'm not gonna
say I'm not going to say and yeah not
enough young people young people not
enough young people let alone not enough
young people caring and so what do you
have left you have an older generation
that does all the voting and they make
all the rules even though they're
clearly not thinking about the future
beyond their life expectancy so it just
stays all in the past and then young
people complain being like well this is
kind of what we grow up with so I guess
we'll just keep going yeah yeah and then
it just never changes yeah and people
used to sometimes people usually can't
be like oh and I used to care about this
because I was down and stupid and no I
don't um you know people used to be like
oh you're you're a foreigner in the
country you can't you can't say anything
I'm like [ __ ] I can't vote and I
pay so much goddamn tax money this
country I think I have an opinion on it
I think
imagine
having an opinion like I'm like I don't
I don't if someone's like you're a
foreigner you don't get a sound like I
actually don't care I'm like [ __ ] you I
pay so much money we don't get it and we
don't get it so the least the least I
can do is I'm gonna complain like a
[ __ ] that is that's the British
if I can't vote I'll complain yeah why
not I mean I don't see why not like I I
think that like this is so much [ __ ]
up [ __ ] yeah and like everyone just
wants to be like no don't say anything
bad and it's like well nothing but
nothing's gonna change unless you make
people care obviously no one who's
watching this video is probably gonna be
able to vote in Japan but I just want to
be able to let you know some of the
complaints that we want shout out to the
160 year old Japanese woman who live in
Japan and have citizenship and can vote
yeah there's nothing more Alpha than
changing the Japanese government yeah I
mean I mean it was funny when you said
uh initially how it started was like oh
yeah we're not having any weddings
recently in Japan and I'm just like wait
I thought I thought this was the year
where it was all weddings because every
wedding has been pushed back to this
year I mean I know several people who
have gone to like who are going and are
going to like several different weddings
and people were just like can people
stop Japanese ones right
your honor I'm going well he said Joe's
going to watch yeah Joe's going to the
only one I'm going to the only one this
year in Japan this is the one of three
Japanese weddings this year
he's going to the point where I've like
had people be like can people just stop
getting [ __ ] married because I've
spent so much money going to wedding I
am people by the way yeah cheers
meanwhile in Japan the wedding office is
like John Travolta
where is it where is it where is it for
one
yeah yeah because uh it's it's it is
definitely the tip of a an iceberg that
I think is just yeah getting bigger and
bigger and bigger it's just you know
until until Japan stops catering to just
old people yeah this stuff isn't going
to change because even like the the tax
benefits they give for kids are decent
like they're good but I don't think
they're enough I don't think what
they're doing is just not enough to like
incentivize people damn how are we going
to change that oh I know maybe letting
immigrants out because that's like the
instrument who can vote like like if you
just uh that would be that far Drake
come on
I don't know how many rights
uh you know like they're it's like it's
fair it's it's like a uh if you want an
instant fix that will that will
definitely fix a population you can just
let them prevent it but a lot of people
don't and they want to find other
Solutions and you know that's every
country has the right to do that but you
know Japan has had this problem now for
for like you know a very very very like
multiple decades and it has to come to a
point where Japan's gonna be like um you
yeah we're we're [ __ ] now I mean you see
it now like you see it really coming
into causing problems with Japan the
economy is is I mean we've seen the
recently in the past few months the Yen
just kind of like bro the Yen just got
good it's like yeah it's running down
mid lane
I just went on a cliff and just
committed a jump King you know it's just
like [ __ ] all the way down there man
I I did a video of on the second Channel
but like the the whole fact that like
Kyoto is going bankrupt yeah it's just
like insane to me I don't think it's
actually going bankrupt I think that was
a like I think it is just I I remember
this video that was like kiddo is not
going bankrupt that's a lie right and I
talked about it and it was something
like so I read like multiple articles
saying no it's definitely going bankrupt
it's I think there's a few citizens
around that have actually gone bankrupt
but I think Kyoto is not at like a risk
I think it was just it's in the red I
think I remember what it was I remember
it wasn't actually going bankrupt but it
was like it was like doing some things
that were you know but one thing that I
in that video that I did find which I
was just not surprised about which might
have been a big you know factor into
that you know whether Kyoto's actually
going bankrupt or not was like I think
it was like because like you know
technically speaking Japan is letting
foreigners in right now yeah technically
technically speaking technically they
have eased their borders yeah right but
like I think there was a report that
said like between June and July 8 000
foreigners have come to Japan yeah it
also decreased in two months there was
also one month where it decreased even
after they loosened the regulations yeah
people people just don't want to come
here right now because the the rules and
regulations even though Japan said oh
wow foreign
[Music]
a lot in the past few months and we're
just like wow how why is Japan still in
the state when the rest of the world
still has you know
have figured out their own solution to
it you know I don't know this is good or
bad but the one thing I realized where
I'm like oh okay in Japan on the thing
every day they still say the daily
covert cases every day yeah on the on
the like the main TV show yeah they
still report them every single day and I
was like oh
okay yeah because like I realized every
other country went to none no one cares
yeah no one talked about it yeah is that
good or bad I don't know but it's just a
noteworthy difference yeah
I'm just trying to give you an idea of
where the Japanese like overall mindset
is at where they still care about the
daily cases that is true yeah like I
feel now in this at this point it's just
fear-mongering did you ever hear anyone
talk about the daily cases in the UK us
or Australia no no no I didn't right no
I just and I I just well in Japan that's
a conversation Style
cases though it's it's the gas prices of
uh
how to get every Japanese person on your
side yeah the covet cases obviously am I
right yeah I'm all right holy [ __ ] it's
actually the highest it's ever been it's
the highest it's ever been yeah it's
like 200 000 a day
but the Japanese would be very quick to
being like it's because we let the
foreigners in it's like no that that
okay that's so [ __ ] annoying it is
annoying it is incredibly annoying
because it's just not it maybe there
might be a factor into that but it's not
only the foreigners you cannot get 200
000 cover cases from just foreigners
they're just it's not like the math
doesn't add up no yeah and like the
thing that is very frustrating is that
they'll say these daily covered cases
and then maybe right after it they'll be
like so we've started learning more
foreigners and it's like they won't say
it they're like it's like some places
are like implying it yeah
and the uh the thing about like for
example the other the trains run like
normal hours in fact people was like
that they didn't mention that at least
yeah right yeah yeah
but what can we do away I don't know
like sometimes about this I'm I don't
know where people stand anymore on like
talking about it they're like What's the
public consensus I don't think many
people do talk about it that's that's it
right yeah and it's like I yeah I don't
know well the thing I find funny is that
uh the pandemic has kind of like made
people forget that other like this like
other illnesses exist and I don't
actually mean forget but I remember just
like you know going to an anime
convention and like when you get sick if
you get sick now everyone assumes
covered yeah but then I remember that
conflict was a thing even before covert
was a thing yeah like you'd go to an
anime conversion you'd go to any
convention you just you just assume
you'd get some kind of illness right
yeah but now I'm just like so paranoid
that every time I'm Ill okay I've just
gotten covered you know yeah I mean in
in Japan like every year around like
november-ish we have this like wave of I
mean this is before covert we used to
have this like wave of influenza that's
just would run rampant in November in
December right and you know it was so
bad in Japan where like now it became
common practice to go get your influenza
shots yeah I haven't for the past two
years I haven't heard anyone who's gone
to get the influenza shot everyone it's
the biggest Baddie of the month right
like it's like covert's the big boy
right now yeah no one cares about it
it's a big box other influenzas yo
they're the beaters man they're the beta
diseases well I'm recently in um other
countries again and we might have a good
or a bad opinion on this I don't know it
depends what you like yeah like uh I
think America just announced why do they
say America uh America just announced
that if you have covered you no longer
need to self-isolate
yeah I think England announced that as
well which I'm I I don't know if I agree
with that uh I don't agree with that I
mean I feel like if you have any illness
you should it's you know it's just
common curse I mean this is a full
covert as well it's like if you have a
cold don't come to work if you have the
flu don't come to work just like it's
yeah I I don't know like I guess it's
weird it's weird because you're like
maybe but maybe not but oh but yeah I
guess like if you have any illness just
you probably shouldn't expose other
people anyway but I guess it's just like
the the feeling of having someone tell
you that you should stay at home versus
just having the courtesies
where like they just won't give them the
sick day as well where you have like
yeah right so it's kind of like yeah
actually we're very lucky that we can if
I want to sell isolate that's just my
normal working hours yeah so
that yeah it's it's a lot harder for
them but but then it's also weird that
like because if you say in this day and
age if you caught a cold or you got
influenza yeah you were just out of just
common thinking you would just be like
oh I probably shouldn't come into work
or I probably shouldn't come to school
well like again no because it's like
so why is that when it suddenly gets to
covert it's like you can't tell me what
to do it's weird as well because like
maybe let's say um you're a teacher or
you're gonna get sick every goddamn week
yeah like you're getting because I mean
those kids are dirty they bring up she's
conflu every week man right so it's like
okay I think a lot of teachers I think
even when they're sick they're going to
work a lot of the time unless they're
really really sick but I think if they
have like a flu sound they just go into
what yeah and also yeah like I said
earlier like you not a lot of jobs you
do not allow people and they a lot of
people can't afford to take time off
work which is a big one yeah well that's
true but like I think like in a
situation where now their homeworking
has become much more of a popular thing
that if you're in a position where you
don't need to expose other people
whatever illness it is you probably just
you know shouldn't shouldn't take that
chance I think that's a that's a good
habit it's it's I think it's a good
habit to promote yeah you know just yeah
don't get don't get other people is that
a hot take I don't know I don't know
then you care for other people what are
her performance but then there's always
that like the covert has that really
[ __ ] annoying part to it where it's
like all right
I I'm I am I feel I am no longer sick I
am totally fine I am still testing
positive do you guys feel comfortable
with me turning out and I'm always like
yeah whatever turn up I don't care yeah
because I'm like I'm I don't live with
anyone I don't interact with anyone who
is elderly or immunocompromised so to me
I'm like if you feel fine I don't care
well I think it's the just the case of I
don't like every case is different yeah
are you still infectious well some
people are some people aren't it's
there's no hard science that says okay
five days in or six days in you aren't
infectious anymore some people might
still be no I know yeah there's like
still like a safety period I guess yeah
I mean I guess it's just like that it's
like the
the placebo kind of feeling of like oh
God isn't coughing everywhere you know
even though I know that you could still
be infectious but also I'm like I'm I
don't know like if we have [ __ ] to do
and it's really important I'm like I'll
be like gone if you're sick I don't care
get me sick get [ __ ] coughing I think
you're I think you're able to say that
because you're the only one in this
officer yeah I think so yeah yeah
I also like I just haven't got it so I
don't know what's happening I've gotten
to the point now where I've been exposed
so many times and I've never gotten it
yeah so I don't know what the [ __ ] is
happening I just found it funny that
it's it was just like you everyone who
everyone I met at every point during my
trip got covered literally everyone that
was this conspiracy theory going around
that Connor was like the episode
like for two months Connor was the alpha
strain he was the Alpha Street look I
don't know like I I'm not trying to be
like irresponsible or be like you should
do this too it's just like I personally
felt I didn't feel uncomfortable yeah if
like if we had to film trash taste and
it was just the three of us and Grant
was sick I would be like I'm happy to
take the risk yeah that's on me yeah if
Joey is too that's on Joey yeah yeah I
feel like we can make those decisions as
reasonable adults right right I don't
know maybe I'm being dumb maybe maybe
I'm [ __ ] crazy no I'm sure this I'm
sure there's yeah I don't agree with
your stance I don't know what the um
normal thought is in terms of covid yeah
because I don't know what it is anymore
not anymore it's like when uh when when
Aki got covered right yeah Joey was like
do you guys feel chill with me coming in
even though I'm testing negative I'm
like yeah [ __ ] yeah you got to do [ __ ]
oh you can't say two he's off what are
we gonna do can't do anything
but that's because we're on a tight
schedule now right but like if we were
on our normal schedule would you have
said the same thing probably because I
I'd still be like I I'm if you are
testing positive I don't care I'm like
whatever come in right but I do care
if I truly didn't care I wouldn't even
take a test yeah let me make that 100
clear I would if I was thought I was
feeling sick I would test and then I
would ask you guys are you comfortable
with it I would never just show up yeah
I feel like that's not my decision to
make yeah of course you know because I
don't if I'm sick it's not my call yeah
like yeah it's up to if you guys are
coming that's why like I was just saying
if you asked me or you asked me I'd be
like I don't care right so you don't
need to ask me all right just [ __ ]
turn off yeah
unless you have like something ligma I
mean
I don't know how infectious that is you
know but like yeah I mean I think it's I
think this is promoted I guess like a
good kind of habit of just at least
asking people because like if you're
sick you should ask him yeah because I
swear before common decency yeah I mean
I I think people before just kind of
like just dumped it out yeah and they
felt like they should tough it out you
know and I know a lot of people where
they go they were in a position where
they felt ill but they were like well
you know I kind of should just tough it
out because the mentality is you know
what Opera why not coming to work why
why are you asking about this you think
the answer should be yes but I feel like
the better mentality is just asking
people are you comfortable with it
because I could be sick because yes uh
in my life before I have got sick from
other people being sick not just this
happened before covid and yes it is
annoying you know so I I think I think
in that sense it's like it's promoted
like good habits I think so yeah
definitely yeah I hope I don't come off
as a [ __ ] crazy person who's like
everyone should [ __ ] be sick all the
time
because you know I mean like even in
Japan that got reflected I remember
there was like a report that came out
during the first year of the pandemic uh
where like the rate of influenza in the
first November went down by like 90 or
something yeah it's just because now
people are just used to being all
hygienic so like we definitely yeah like
a lot of definitely a lot of [ __ ] things
happen because of this but also a lot of
like people yeah gained a lot of good
habits no I have not got a conflu yet
and I see that as a [ __ ] positive
exactly I used to get conflu every
single time before the pandemic it was
always the default I am going to an
anime convention I am going to get ill
and there's nothing I can do about it
but now yes people still do get ill
after Anime conventions of course it
doesn't spread as much anymore because
people are carrying around [ __ ] hand
sanitizer but people are at least more
aware of Health thing health issues
maybe weaves shower like 10 more I don't
know what the exact number is but I feel
like people shower more L it took a
global pandemic before we used to
finally shower
thank God
we could be proud of that at least yeah
oh oh my God yeah I I think that is that
is a positive that people are just more
health conscious and more conscious
about the people around them you know
definitely yeah definitely I think
everyone's become a bit more of a
germaphobe yeah oh yeah like just
because you had to yeah or malin's like
fine oh my God finally my people my
people I finally see more people like me
yeah mailings finally not as weird as
she used to be still weird but not as
weird but hey look at all these Alpha
sigmas on our patreon right now look at
that look at these fellow Alpha
herbivores Alpha herbivores alphabets
if you'd like to become an alpha
herbivore and support the show then go
over to our patreon patreon.com trash
days also follow us on Twitter send us
some memes on the subreddit and you've
had our face listen to us on Spotify but
uh yeah uh keep being Alphas
that's it Joey that's how you're ending
it now what was the alpha con tagline
again I don't know I was like don't be a
[ __ ]
be great or be nothing at all don't be
stupid don't be stupid be Alpha
[Music]